in a football stadium a match between
two arch Rivals has begun The Spectators
are enjoying every second of it and
cheering for their respective teams
however one particular man seems to be
scared he knows something that no one
else does that the stadium will explode
if the noise level exceeds 100 decibels
there is an indicator inside the stadium
that displays the noise levels as the
scared looking man is on the phone
talking about the possible explosion a
fan overhears him and inquires about the
matter with an anxious look The Man
reveals everything about the possible
explosion he then asserts that if a goal
is scored the noise levels will
obviously increase hearing this the fan
becomes worried but he knows what he is
supposed to do he has to prevent any
goals until the final whistle
unfortunately the home team gets a
penalty chaos is about to unfold but in
the nick of time the fan heroically runs
to the pitch and kicks the ball this
delays the explosion for the time being
but can he delay it until the full time
whistle following this the movie goes
into a flashback in the depth of the
Ocean east of Hiroshima a Korean
submarine named Hala is passing through
inside there are several Navy officers
trying to protect their country from
attackers the leader of the group is
Kang doe young he is the same scared man
from the first scene unfortunately one
day they come under heavy fire as an
enemy submarine starts bombarding them
with missiles Kang calms his crew down
and tries his best to guide them towards
safety but is unsuccessful at the end
Hala crashes at the bottom of the ocean
the scene then fast forwards by a year
and Kang who is still alive has started
Living a normal life he has retired from
his duties and spends most of his time
with his wife Yu Jiang and their
daughter's Soul one day as he is heading
to a press meeting suddenly he receives
a call from an unknown number the person
on the other end explains that
explosives have been planted at an
amusement park and also at a Major's
house he then asks Kang to select a
location of the two but as expected the
latter hangs up following this Kang
attends the Press meeting where he is
asked about the submarine disaster that
killed many crew members one of the
reporters even asks Kang if he did
anything to help the situation at all
however he does not answer any of them
and remains silent now that's how you do
a press conference next the major
receives a parcel at his home and on
opening it he finds a bomb inside at the
same time another bomb is found at the
amusement park as mentioned by the
anonymous caller sadly before the major
can react the bomb explodes leaving his
whole family injured in the next scene
Kang's wife Yu Jiang receives a call
informing her to arrive at the amusement
park as soon as possible right then the
bomber calls Kang and orders him to
install an app on his phone he explains
that the app will block all other calls
and messages apart from his Kang
obviously thinks the entire thing is BS
and refuses to comply but when the
caller threatens to detonate the next
bomb he hurriedly installs the app as
soon as he installs the app he receives
the next location which is going to be
bombed to Kang's horror it is the city's
largest football stadium Asiatic main
Arena before hanging up the bomber warns
Kang against informing the police and
gives him 60 Minutes to save the people
in the stadium Kang wastes no time and
rushes to the Asiatic main Arena where a
club football match is being held he
goes inside the stadium and immediately
starts panicking after noticing the
sheer number of Spectators there
moreover finding a tiny bomb inside this
time frame is also virtually impossible
just then the bomber calls Kang and
gives him some instructions firstly the
bomb works on sound if the noise inside
the stadium reaches 100 decibels it will
get activated the bomber also reveals
that the bomb is inside the VIP sitting
area well that's not the worst thing in
the world only Psychopaths can afford
those seats in the meantime a news
reporter O'Day here's Kang talking to
the bomber he recognizes him as the
captain of the doomed holla submarine
and inquires if everything is okay Kang
simply mentions that a bomb is going to
explode if they make too much noise
before walking away hearing this oday
becomes terrified and he starts
brainstorming ideas on how to control
the crowd when nothing comes up he
covers his mouth and rushes to the field
in an attempt to distract everyone the
plan works for a while and the crowd
becomes silent but soon he is taken away
and the match resumes meanwhile Kang is
still on his way to the VIP sitting area
which is exactly on the opposite side of
the stadium unfortunately at the same
time the match goes to penalties and a
player scores a goal this prompts the
crowd to go wild and the sound level
easily crosses 100 decibels hence
activating the bomb soon after an
anxious Kang reaches the location and
starts searching the room haphazardly
luckily he finds the bomb inside an
aquarium and takes it out he then asks
everyone in the VIP area to evacuate all
the people comply and they rush to
safety however one kid is Left Behind
with only five seconds on the bomb timer
Kang who is already out sees this and
rushes to save the kid he covers her
body with his and at the same time the
bomb explodes fortunately both of them
survive and this Kang walks out of the
room holding the little kid everyone
claps for him with respect he still blew
it with the submarine buddy but good job
later as Kang is leaving the stadium he
again receives a call from the bomber
who reveals the next Target it turns out
to be a local swimming pool resort which
is always sprawling with people the
timer also starts which is for exactly
60 minutes since the resort is very far
away Kang asks the reporter O'Day to
lend his car for the day the latter
obliges but only on the condition that
he can join Kang doesn't want to
endanger anyone but since he doesn't
have much time he agrees on the other
hand as Seoul is returning home alone
she gets kidnapped meanwhile Kang
showcases his impeccable driving skills
and manages to reach the resort in a
matter of minutes but in the process he
breaks every traffic rule imaginable
right then Kang receives a call from the
bomber and this time he also receives a
picture it is of his daughter Soul who
has been tied and placed inside a black
car the picture devastates Kang but he
quickly regroups and focuses on the task
at hand he then proceeds to the swimming
pool but not before ordering oday to
search for the black car shortly after
Kang starts looking for the bomb around
the area he suspects that it is inside
the water like the last time and
surprisingly he is correct to get a
closer look Kang Dives inside the pool
and tries to disarm it elsewhere at the
amusement park his wife Yu Jiang has
arrived at the scene wearing a bomb suit
it turns out that she is one of the best
bomb diffusers in the city and that's
why she has been called upon
unfortunately while she is trying to
concentrate a couple living in the
nearby apartment makes a loud noise this
activates the bomb and the clock starts
ticking at this instant we are shown the
scenes of two different places the
swimming pool and the amusement park
where the husband and wife are both
trying to defuse bombs the situation is
tense in both places and in the end they
decide to Shield the bomb with their own
bodies hoping that it can save people I
guess neither of them are very happy
with their marriage however when the
timer runs out nothing happens officers
at the amusement park assume that it is
a prank but right then Kang receives a
call that is connected to the timer near
his wife now both of them can hear each
other Yu Jiang can also see a picture of
her kidnapped daughter inside the timer
then the bomber speaks up and reveals
that a large explosive is set under the
ground where Yu Jiang is standing she
can run but if she does so little soul
will be killed Kang who is hearing
everything begs his wife to run away but
she doesn't move an inch a short while
later a large explosion occurs which
tosses her a few meters away at the
parking lot odey discovers the black car
he was looking for and somehow opens the
door but as soon as he does so a small
explosion occurs causing him minor
injuries Kang also arrives at the scene
but doesn't find any signs of his
daughter inside the car in the following
scene we are finally shown The
Mastermind behind all the terror attacks
he is Tae siong ex-navy who is a part of
the Hollis submarine when it came under
attack his brother was also in the
submarine but he passed away on that
fateful day now tasyong is doing all of
this to take revenge on the government
and Kang for their arbitrary decisions
elsewhere the city's section chief
officer young Han is informed about the
explosion at the amusement park he is
also told that the bomb defuser Yu Jiang
is still alive which makes her an
obvious Target for the bomber hence
young Han asks his driver to take him to
the hospital immediately but before they
can reach it tasyong enters Jiang Yu's
medical room and kills her security
guard on the other hand Kang and O'Day
go to meet an ex-navy officer and
inquire about tasyong's whereabouts the
latter gives them an address and so the
search begins after a while Kang enters
the perpetrator's house where he finds a
lot of material scattered around these
are the same materials that are used to
make the bombs right then Kang receives
a call from tayceon who holds him
responsible for the death of his other
co-officers Kang tries his best to
justify himself but tasion does not
listen and suggests that he meet him at
the Mist Hotel after this disguising
himself as a doctor taseyong takes Yu
Jiang out of her room in a wheelchair to
the hallway in the meantime young Han
also arrives there but fails to
recognize the perpetrator he instead
goes straight to yujiyong's room and
finds her guard lying dead on the floor
alarmed he orders his driver to scan the
whole area for taseyong the latter does
find him and initiates a fight but in
the process he gets killed allowing
tacion to drive away with Jang Yu
meanwhile a worried Kang calls young Han
and explains the entire situation to him
he also reveals about the bomb related
materials found at the perpetrator's
house soon Kang and oday arrive at the
Mist Hotel and begins searching for the
bomber but instead they find Little Seal
sleeping on a couch wearing a jacket
covered with explosives meanwhile young
Han and his team inspect the
perpetrator's house and to deduce that
the explosives are connected to
different ships and it is difficult to
defuse them elsewhere tasyong enters the
seminar Hall of the Mist Hotel wearing
another jacket full of explosives and
greets the crowd hearing his voice Kang
rushes to the hall and confronts him he
tries his best to calm the bomber down
but to no avail tasion keeps on accusing
Kang for the death of his brother Tae
Rion and several other officers he also
belittles him for taking advantage of
the situation for his own benefit
following this we are taken into a
flashback it has been 11 days since Hala
has been stuck at the bottom of the
ocean Tyrion can be seen talking to his
brother and mentioning that he has full
faith in Captain Kang and his ability to
save them right then Kang receives a
telegram message from the headquarters
stating that it will take around 15 days
for help to arrive with only 19 percent
oxygen left in the submarine the Navy
officers start to panic hence to control
the situation and save as many officers
as possible Kang comes up with a plan he
cuts a string into different lengths and
informs the officers that whoever gets
the longest length of string Will
Survive and the others will have to
sacrifice themselves one by one the
officers start pulling the strings from
Kang's hand and let fate decide their
survival tasion gets a longer strength
while his brother Tae Rion pulls shorter
one devastated tacy young tries to
protest against the captain but he is
pushed away then right before his eyes
Tae Rion and the others who got shorter
strengths are forced to leave the place
back to the present taseyang tells Kang
that his wife is trapped inside a car
parked outside the hotel now he only has
three minutes to save both his daughter
and wife he also mentions that Kang
needs to take the jacket he is wearing
near both to disable the timers with the
clock ticking by Tae siong makes the
situation even more difficult by
attacking Kang the two go back and forth
for a while but in the end young Han
arrives and shoots taseyang dead
following this with only about 90
seconds left Kang jumps from the top
floor of the missed hotel and manages to
reach his wife he then defuses the bomb
in the nick of time and saves her but by
this time only 23 seconds are left on
the timer so without caring about
anything else he drives the car inside
the building and finally reaches his
daughter he then gets out of the car and
defuses the bomb right before it
explodes in the last scene Kang accepts
his mistake and takes responsibility for
the dead officers in front of the media
he mentions that the incident happened
because of his silly decisions and that
he should have acted more wisely the
movie ends with Kang visiting the
Tombstones of the deceased soldiers and
giving them his final tribute subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching